Da staunen nicht nur Star-Trek-Fans: Mitten
in der Hellas-Tiefebene, dem größten Impaktkrater
des Mars, hat die NASA-Sonde “Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter" eine wirklich kuriose Aufnahme gemacht.
Es ist das Bild einer Erhebung, die wirklich
täuschend echt an das bekannte Logo von Star
Trek erinnert. Wie ist es auf den Roten Planeten
gekommen und warum geht ganz Twitter deswegen
jetzt steil?! Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier
gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. Herzlich willkommen!
(und danke für Euren Themenvorschlag über
Telegram)! Die NASA selbst twittert zu ihrer
neusten Entdeckung: “Enterprising viewers
will make the discovery that these features
look conspicuously like a famous logo.”Übersetzt
also in etwa sowas wie: Aufmerksame Beobachter
könnten bemerken, dass das hier aussieht
wie ein bekanntes Logo! “Enterprising”
ist in diesem Kontext ja ein wirklich passender
Wortwitz! Beam me down to Mars Scotty oder
was?! Aber jetzt mal im Ernst: Nicht nur eingefleischte
Star-Trek-Fans werden wohl auf der Aufnahme
der NASA-Sonde “Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter"
das Logo von Star-Trek erkennen können. Inmitten
der Sanddünen des Mars also eine wirklich
kuriose Entdeckung. Auch Fachleute haben sich
damit intensiv beschäftigt und stellen jetzt
klar, dass die Ähnlichkeit zu dem Star-Trek-Logo
wohl purer Zufall ist. Entstanden ist diese
faszinierende Mars-Formation wohl durch langwierige
geologische Prozesse. Aufgespürt wurde sie
im Bereich der Hellas-Tiefebene, dem größten
Einschlagkrater des Mars auf seiner südlichen
Hemisphäre. Er ist etwa 2.200 Kilometer mal
1.600 Kilometer groß und hat eine elliptische
Form. Mit seiner Tiefe von neun Kilometern
handelt es sich um die tiefste Region des
Roten Planeten. Auf ihrer Website erklärt
die NASA die Entstehung dieser sogenannten
Chevron-Formen, die die Experten auch als
“Dünenabgüsse” bezeichnen. Demnach sind
sie das Ergebnis eines komplexen Zusammenspiels
von Wind, Lava und Dünen. Alles begann mit
einer sichelförmigen Düne, die sich zu einer
Insel im Lava-Meer entwickelte. Diese sichelförmigen
Dünen werden in der Fachsprache auch als
“Barchan-Dünen” bezeichnet - auf dem
Mars machen sie einen Großteil der Dünen
aus. Irgendwann erstarrte die Lava und die
Dünen ragten weiterhin aus ihr hervor. Durch
den Wind wurde der Sand weggeweht und diese
“Fußspuren” verblieben in der Lava-Ebene.
Aber auch andere “Fachleute” beschäftigt
diese Entdeckung. Zum Beispiel Captain Kirk
selbst, also William Shattner. Der twittert
(am 13. Juni 2019):
Hey @starwars! Will you hurry up your Rebel
Scums? We beat you!
https://twitter.com/WilliamShatner
Vom Star Wars-twitter-Account kam dann schnell
die recht eindeutige Antwort (13.6.19)
“@starwars: We’re ‘far far away’ from
that tiny red planet.”
(https://twitter.com/starwars)
Sogar Mark Hamil, der Luke Skywalker in “Krieg
der Sterne” spielt, gibt seinen Senf zu
der Entdeckung auf dem Mars:
@HamillHimself: Looks like a boomerang to
me. #Meh
(https://twitter.com/HamillHimself)
Übrigens ist das keinesfalls eine Premiere,
denn schon in der Vergangenheit wurden überaus
kuriose Motive auf der Marsoberfläche entdeckt.
Beispielsweise Pac Man oder aber Muppet Beaker.
Bilder:
https://mars.nasa.gov/resources/21854/barchan-pac-man/
https://www.cnet.com/news/nasa-spots-beaker-the-muppet-in-bug-eyed-mars-formation/
Auch “Games of Thrones” war schon auf
dem Roten Planeten zu “Gast”. Link unter
Quellen Zumindest erinnert eine Aufnahme einer
Staubspur auf dem Mars stark an das Wappentier
von “Haus Stark”. Dieses Muster entstand
wohl durch eine Staublawine, die sich durch
einen Objekt-Einschlag gelöst hatte - der
Staub hatte so diese dunkle Sand-Schicht freigelegt.
Alle diese kuriosen Aufnahmen stammen übrigens
von HiRISE - diese Abkürzung steht für “High
Resolution Imaging Science Experiment” und
befindet sich wie gesagt an Bord der Sonde
„Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter“. Die hochauflösende
Kamera macht gezielt Aufnahmen von Formationen
auf dem Mars, die durch geologische und klimatische
Prozesse entstanden sind. Und jetzt eine kleine
Pirouette: Auch auf dem Mond wurden während
der ersten Mondlandung zahlreiche Aufnahmen
gemacht und am 20. Juli streamen wir zwölf
Stunden lang “live” von der Mondlandung
vor 50 Jahren. Sekundengenau mit all dem Wissen,
das wir heute haben. Mit dabei: die Astronauten
Gerhard Thiele und Reinhold Ewald, die wir
vorab interviewt haben und zahlreiche Wissenschaftsyoutuber.
Wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt, dann klickt
hier und merkt euch den Stream vor. Um 21
Uhr am Samstag, den 20. Juli geht es los.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!